toss a coin to your witcher oh my god
yasuki's been he's he's in trouble
that's where we last left off that's
right last week on the witcher
yaska gets himself just spotted
all right guys episode five today been
enjoying this season thus far thank you
so much for joining us on this journey
you guys go ahead and hit that like
button i mean a lot toss a coin to that
subscribe button subscribe to get
accepted to the reject tribe we're
working on that
full-length watch launcher stick up with
the timecode over at our patreon page we
come with super reject today by checking
out everything we got to offer
yeah
terminology slang the way youtubers do
boys that prepper thank you so much for
watching
[Music]
by the pricking of my thumbs
what is
only the white flame is hunting her but
when others learn of her they'll want to
do the wild hunt
my freedom in exchange for being the
white flames bounty under
sounds pretty sweet
i don't remember did we met this guy i
don't think so
i if he if we have i'll need a reminder
[Music]
we're playing with time again i'm
already confused
the whole test has fortified bruges
beyond recognition
his annoyance provided exposition
oh no
hello
is anyone there
oh
so why don't you just show yourself and
we can have a nice chat and you can tell
me what you want from me
hello yes yes
[Music]
i said who the [ __ ] are you dad
dad
my name is gerald aprivia
you're both banged the same woman
awkward
do you know of the suicide tower just
outside the city it fell
during the slaughter of sintra
and now a new subspecies of monsters are
coming out of it is that they were
nesting in the subterranean structure
for years
which might explain the unique mutations
oh so you're the historian now i'm
trying to help elves find refuge here
you have any idea how completely [ __ ]
insane you sound
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my god the prostitutes back then i
needed to go to the garrison and see if
any little [ __ ] birds under the name of
fiasco have been caged you go into all
that trouble paying someone for such a
simple task
half when you return
ah
well then
never look a gift door in the mouth
that's what my mom would tell me all the
time you too
back on the road that's all right
that's right i'm an official researcher
for fringe la vigo time to kill these
people [ __ ] you're trespassing no
guardian land please still be reasonable
we're passing through we don't want that
[ __ ] death you're [ __ ] stupid
i said
oh
yeah
stay where you are
yeah that's gonna help
he took care of his you took care of his
given up on magic lessons already you're
all said that when you know how to fight
something it becomes less threatening
can take on a thousand sec men now
we don't know that elder blood can make
witcher mutagen we don't even really
know what it is you
me
that's siri we have a chance to do
something extraordinary i like you
better when you're a cynical culture
this doesn't sound like it's gonna go
well at all
if we do this
it's because she wants to she gets to
decide what's with giving women choices
nowadays it's just her blood come on
what are you doing to my bard i wasn't
expecting this
mm-hmm
so tight-lipped about your old friend
the witcher
oh man i don't know where they're going
and i don't know
why you're doing this to me
it's such a shame you can't be useful no
oh [ __ ] that or no are you serious dude
do not i have to draw it you need a
source
fire is a forbidden sauce because it
usually consumes those that draw from it
please don't tell me this guy is the key
to getting yen's magic back
[Music]
please i don't know anything no no no no
the songs in your catalogue would
suggest otherwise
he does not
her friends and he does not
have
weaknesses
stop it man
leaving me at home throughout uh uh this
is this is my wife she has nothing to do
with this please let her go what's good
for you leave if you knew what's good
for you
you'd shut the [ __ ] up
oh no please don't hurt just leave her
alone please she's done nothing
good girl
oh these two together
hell yeah
and them two together
it's just everyone's assistance
i really built that
i have to go down there well you have to
go down there
oh yeah
talk about how you both did jennifer
that's right that's the place to do it
maybe they can play around with each
other
you're impressing all of us up there
not enough to join garrelton cintra you
think you should have been invited
what's my home
my fight
my life
i need to show you something
this is an animated movie called
nightmare
only grows one place
where elder blood has spilled
these have been sprouting life the
training course yeah
put it together come on
my grandmother she hated the owls
sometimes our deepest hate is for the
things we cannot change about ourselves
hey yeah you're talking man i get you
with a vial of your blood we could
protect generations to come are you so
sure it will work
i'm not
i'll do it
in one condition you have to test it on
me first
[Applause]
you said it yourself witches are dying
one by one you'll fight
he'll die and all of those boys
suffering will have been for nothing
but if you die then they can't produce
more so it'll still have been for night
please just
let me destroy myself heal something for
once
i'm meant for this i guess you really
wait till geralt gets back that's all
i'm saying
nah i just kick-started right now
conjunction like that would require two
things a massive surge of energy and and
and conduits to channel it now what if
the monoliths aren't points of impact
what if they're the conduits
oh no
you say this monolith double during the
slaughter of centre that makes perfect
sense and yet it doesn't
oh god
oh yep yep yep
well that must have been very pleasant
in this day and age
oh my god i'm surprised she went along
with it yeah
it worked
i just need a moment to prepare
just gotta go vlog
oh my god you guys we did it no magic
remember
[ __ ] you don't get to play damsel in
distress
oh
that's my job
[Laughter]
not bad
come back here
[Music]
the underground prostitute network
oh you're always
bad prostitute
i'm not afraid have you thought about
geralt
what he'd say
everything i was told my whole life was
a lie and the people i loved most in
this world were taken from me before i
could find the truth what you're doing
won't change any of that maybe there's
another way to find out where your
powers came from reading a book
i don't like this memory man the amount
of psychological trauma you could uproot
and lead a better life
we've been right here
the whole time
sir come on wait i don't want to leave
him yet something isn't right
oh this is terrifying i know
my skin is crawling
is it the same old lady the witch lady
which lady it sounded like it the
deathless mother it wasn't a conjunction
at least not how we were thinking the
other spheres didn't merge they
they collided and separated again
oh the original spheres are still out
there somewhere and all monoliths are
calling to them there's gonna be another
conversion monsters aren't new they just
need to hear and they're using arm on
leicester's gateways
thunder clap means you're correct so
many more monsters
i came to central because i thought
someone might be here
a woman
now you've done it oh now they're going
to fight each other
jennifer
you know unit
yen
yes
me too
now tell geralt
some fleeting senator she's alive
after she burned through nilfgaard's
army and saved the continent we should
all be praising her name
ian's alive oh
buddy
you both can love her together
it's a new time man polyamory
[Music]
and now my sweet daughter
you will destroy
of elder blood
child of wrath the time of contempt is
nigh
the world will die amidst frost and be
reborn of the new son
reborn of elder
wow revelations
oh
[Music]
no
oh my god
something is ending
it's because of you
oh no
you will destroy us all
no one can stop it
not even him should have just become a
witcher
left all this mind palace business to
rest where did those status on fragments
go
whose voice was that client keep telling
me about you
did you say anything about me
oh oh oh
horses
oh [ __ ]
there we go
oh
all right
oh no
cool
stellasite dragon
[ __ ]
do you think nope god knows about this
open a portal now
listen i want it done
now oh oh golly
do you think this is gonna prevent it
from
no hey geralt this is a portal
portal faster
what are you doing
carol she's meant to be to rebuild us
she is not no matter how hard i train no
matter what i do it will never be enough
you are already enough sorella you
should love yourself
we can't kill our feelings our best
chance is to kill the hatred that we may
hold on to and move on
some sage life advice
so henry cavill feels about the dc
i can't just forget about man of steel
[Applause]
[Music]
this is nilfgaard i guess so
this is our first time seeing nilfgaard
right
since geralt took on this yeah yeah
i am commander more different up killick
who the [ __ ] are you
and commander
i'm kidding who the hell are you i'm
dally old saint nick good to see you
alive
ain't no thanks to you
you know
oh no
i'm simply a guy to get you exactly what
you deserve
just ask your friends read the secret
i've earned it i deserve access to chaos
i know how you can get it
how you can steal it steal what
me
[Music]
no
don't do this
show it
all you have to do is deliver me to the
right it's right there
a shattered black door just outside
adventure
no no
i say do it
yeah
until very next episode why not we need
just one character to be like english
please you know what i mean guys you
need an audience cipher hanging around
caramorin and everywhere else that
anybody import is hanging no no no no no
this actually doesn't make sense it's
just
people i mean
i'm making that jokes because you know
when you're
like i felt the same way like oh it was
right in front of us the whole time the
idea
of uh jennifer having to
essentially was like deliver siri right
yeah yeah having to deliver siri to a
spot like you could see that if you just
pay attention like yeah of course that
would be there would be something
involving siri ultimately
and
uh when you
are so caught up in the moment of just
there's so much information we're
learning about conduits and models right
now
spheres is where i really start to get
lost and like all these different
spheres came together yeah it blew apart
and now they're still separate but they
can connect no no long story short model
like monoliths are gateways yeah
activate the activate the monoliths
monsters concepts come out bam easy said
and done all right what's so hard about
that
why the witchers need to bother creating
monsters
elder magic none of this in world
dialogue we need anymore all right let's
have people talk like dumb americans
just to make life easier for it put a
crawl of the cliffs notes on the bottom
of the screen this needs to be like a
summary it's a really quick like instead
of something for dummies
because i'm like i think i get it but
could you clarify it so i don't miss a
bunch of other info wondering if i've
got it correctly going back over the
details of my mind
it was interesting it started off with
that uh fire mage guy
yes snappy magee and yet i wondered if
that was what he was doing that whole
time like do you just like trying to
flint spark and you can't because you're
in jail
yeah i think the jail that he was in
prevented him
that pretty much oppresses his powers
magic jail him magic jail that's how it
works
it's the best kind of i thought he was
gonna turn into maybe i'm assuming he'll
come back in some way he's gotta come
back or maybe not because like they gave
him this
such a focused introduction like you're
gonna be the assassin oh yeah you gotta
be afraid of this guy gonna be
[Music]
yeah and then he just gets some fire in
his face and then he's just like gone
for the episode yeah that was lucky
yeah i mean i i gotta imagine he'll come
back i mean i liked his presence on
screen but if this is all that we see of
him then then yeah he is a glorified
mustache twirler but i enjoyed his time
when he was there absolutely i enjoyed
his time and i like that interrogation
scene literally there's a lot of great
things that came uh from this episode
from you know tris and siri geralt and
uh
that's not his name
it's lenny kraft kravitz
forget it sorry
gary rivers and lenny kravitz yeah
geralt's and uh is traded
like no all like there's so much to
unpack there
and you know having especially but
especially with siri of like oh never
mind you were
at one camp you are seen as savior in
the other camp you are
ruined and destroyer yeah the apocalypse
bringer
yeah so it's it's such um
it's such an important episode uh for
that revelation to unpack and then all
for
the weight of the world literally to be
put on her shoulders and the choices she
has to make moving forward and if this
truth gets out
like holy [ __ ] what what do we do about
her and carol's not gonna let anything
happen to her
uh
but really my favorite [ __ ] is all with
uh i would have to say is is with
jennifer and
um it's hard to love the two of them
yeah
like i really loved the way the show uh
handled all the story elements it was
all very intriguing like more of the
geralt and this red stuff was more the
thinking cap you know because it's like
they're just spouting information back
you're literally just finding stuff out
yeah yeah and so i really enjoyed that
uh and i like seeing them together they
have good chemistry
uh but watching just jennifer and ask
here there's i don't know there's
something more rewarding and cathartic
about it and a little bit more nostalgic
i suppose just because of the fact that
he's finally back and also the change of
relationship that's occurred with them
and how they managed to kind of keep
some of that banter even though
you know she's not exactly who she is
but you could feel they really care
about each other even though it's not
being spoken aloud it's that relief of
seeing a friendly face in a desolate
situation yeah that kind of clicks that
friendship where it used to be like
especially for me ask yours and he used
to be like i don't want to get too close
to you and turn in times of survival
mode they are looking out for each
other's
survival as well so i think that's what
there's something more just immediate
about what's going on with them yeah and
i i really
really love them together that's that
was
even though it's actually the least of
the episode
that's
weirdly my favorite part about it you
know yeah i really like them just both
together in you know banter but also
together in you know having to evade
being caught in and the mess that the
situation they're in has turned into and
her trying to bribe this prostitute to
trying to rescue him and then
in ways having to try and rescue each
other it's funny because i think you
know this could have felt and especially
too going along with yennefer's loss of
power and whatnot i feel like both of
these things could have felt like wheel
spinning and here they don't to me feel
like that i feel like
the way it's been timed with jennifer's
plight and then just yeah this whole
mess that's become of finding the
sandpiper and getting onto the ship and
even kahir actually takes the voyage but
like the way that they all get displaced
through this felt pretty natural and now
it's like what are the stakes next time
because it seems like yes you're going
to be stranded and jennifer is on a
different plane right now and i have to
imagine that the deathless mother can
you know spit her out wherever she wants
to
so uh they're they're good at like
mixing up the pieces and then you know
making you feel the sort of peril and
making relationships like that i think
feel more tangible because you know next
episode i'm like god is the other
frigging to be separated from him again
is you ask you're gonna be on his own
damn i want to see them together
you know
yeah
we'll see how this all plays out
it seems like he was about to unpack
something very revelatory it did yeah
yeah it really did
i'm not sure what it would what it would
have been but um
definitely my second favorite part would
have to be the whole thing with tris
and
uh
and and siri mind hopping and yeah going
into the mind palace
the uh
i don't know what it's called but anyway
but yeah but going into that i thought
like that's that's something that i've
seen done in many
many types of
literature or
actually
you know movies and shows
and screws i have read i've seen that
done quite a bit but i thought they i
liked i really liked the way they
visually realized it because normally
all it is is
like a hall of ominous past
which it does become that but i like how
the working backwards
like it seems like she kind of walks
into
a
a pub of sort of a tavern she walks into
like a tavern and then it's like
memories are kind of just sitting around
her on around the table like everywhere
around her bizarre of your own
experiences yeah so it's like it's
slowly moving backwards through like
pretty much the seasons uh like season
two and season one of this show
and then unpacking this whole thing with
i'm still trying to fully understand
what it was well we're not meant to
fully understand it's not even tris
really quite got it yeah
but
something about and maybe it'll probably
make clearer in the next episode this is
what i mean this is one of the
information episodes where i'm like let
me just make sure i got this down soak
all this in
that
so from elder bluster she's elf
yes
amazing part elf it's the same thing
right i think so yeah
that she's part elf
and
all i really got was the submarine which
is she's meant to destroy the world
yeah she's meant to bring along one of
those prophetic yeah like you know the
winter will crush and give way to the
new sun and yeah
which i have a feeling will be
interpretable in multiple directions
perhaps depending on it's like you know
the white flame has been searching for
her clearly he must have some kind of
her they whoever they are must have some
idea
of this to be you know on the lookout
for her anyway but yeah it's clear that
she is connected to an ancient
and very significant source of power and
heritage
so who
was
that person
the elf and the yeah the one who like
started choking tris
i don't know i'm not sure i mean i i
don't think we're supposed to know yet
because at first i thought it was it was
um
but it's not uh yeah honestly this
season has been like [ __ ] yeah man this
one's easy to follow and then this
episode wait a minute oh my god
yeah yeah
and i'm always afraid to be like i think
it's a mystery left for next time
because that's going to be the thing
where people were like it's so obviously
explained right there
but no i love the way that that whole
sequence was captured both yeah with
just the visual and set you know the
design of the representation of the
inside of her mind yeah this little pub
area and then moving out into these more
sort of just like vast uh you know
planes and thickets and stuff and well
it seemed like she went into flashback
slash prophetic landscape
like it was like combined slapped
together yeah well also the whole thing
with like genealogy memories yeah
something i've always been fascinated
with is like is that possible because
i'm like access that that's a concept
that was introduced to me uh yeah and i
was like a kid it was uh i think it was
jeff bridges movie it was jeff altered
states i think was the movie
oh yeah i can see the poster in my head
yeah i think i think that's what that
dealt with is like accessing memories in
genealogy i'm pretty sure it's that
movie
and uh so it's such a weird
idea
but i love the way they did it here
because some stuff started becoming
present yeah and taking hold
of the memory which made it
scary because
before you're like well this is just
safe and a kind of a convenient little
thing now that we've unpacked so that's
why we're stanford
this is amazing all of our characters
should get this treatment you can learn
so much about yourself and let some [ __ ]
go away yeah this is amazing this is a
great trauma therapy right here not many
more songs yesterday yeah
yeah there's so much to impact here but
then
uh when it started becoming like
actually something threatening and the
way how it it's i like how seam
work-wise it starts off with tris
you know wanting to be like you know we
can't do that witcher stuff
here's a positive solution and it's safe
yeah
you're just
and then
and then i like how it just ends where
she chris is like get the [ __ ] out of my
face
yeah and it's like it's there
you know they are tropes that are used
but i thought they were used to great
effect here both that the whole sort of
like i i suggested this and now i'm the
one who's like super spooked but also
just the slow s fade in of the
ominousness of that whole experience
where at first yeah you're like of
course it's gonna be a little strange
this is kind of cool and then it yeah it
gets more and more foreboding until you
know each time tris is like this isn't
right i was getting more and more on
edge and i i really liked in general for
this episode kind of branching out for
that you know everything surrounding
siri because i feel like in a lesser
show or with more trite writing they
would have had her you know in a lot
more of like spats and things with all
of the adult figures around her who are
trying to
you know sculpt her path and act in her
best interest it's like i really
appreciated that like when tris does
intervene and she's like i don't know if
you should go through this witcher
transformation why don't we go try this
other safer method first i like that
that becomes like okay
yeah let's actually try that as much as
siri has her heart set on this it
doesn't become a reason to spin wheels
and have some kind of you know ah you
know i don't want to talk to truce
anymore you know it's like the
web of like geralt's wishes for her
and uh everything with vestemir and the
way they handled him being like well if
you want to do it first i don't want to
have any part of this either like i
thought they did a really nice character
nuances and choices surrounding her
whole debate because that could have
easily become annoying uh but especially
too with just freya allen's performance
like i was really engrossed in the st
the ever expanding plight of what it
means to be siri yeah i know
i think yeah most shows probably would
have written a very annoying child
character yes and i'm so happy they did
it
no they made her
they've made her very human like i
understood her
so you
in another show you might have just been
like ah she's so [ __ ] arrogant i
can't stand her
but they've let her character slowly
reveal herself and what's going on
internally over the course of two
seasons
and she's become a character i'm very
much endeared towards and like how she
she had that whole speech prior to the
like when she's talking with i think
it's with chris so tristar vesper one of
the two
about
i'm trying to i think of a triss
actually like i'm trying to find a path
and my whole world i've known has been
shattered
i've been on the run
everything's a lie
and i'm just trying to find some purpose
yeah and find some truth and i'm trying
to tell someone i'm trying to understand
why i am the way i am
if my blood is supposed to be i know she
didn't say this but it's kind of
uninterpreted like if my blood is
supposed to be
the thing that helps create more
witchers maybe i'm meant to be a witcher
myself
and
how she does find the answers here and
yet it's
not at all what you the truth sometimes
doesn't set you free yeah you know
doesn't help you gain any more control
but the way how it it end like it's such
a
it's such a um just a just a harrowing
thing that she has to
uh to learn about herself
but how they brought it back with geralt
and her
when he steps in to intervene before the
witcher process takes place
like a lot of
there's so many i think that a lot of
these chara they do such a good job with
these characters they internalize so
much like vesamir
you know they starts off like i'm not
desperate i'm hopeful but i'm like i
think you're a little desperate
and i think in that moment before he
injected her
you know we they have this he has a look
where after
geralt walks away and he's like looking
at the
the injection gun yeah yeah and he is
you just see this look of realization on
his face like what did i almost just
succumbed to what did i get because i
was [ __ ] desperate
and then with geralt having this
the way they've ridden him is so good
because
season could just be too much
they could easily just go way too much
where and they've managed to to just
choose the moments
where he is just the right moments to
pull something out of him where you're
like this guy's actually a sweetheart
dad of the year yeah to just be like you
are enough
you're you're you're amazing you know
yeah
yeah we need to improve your self-talk
yeah i love i love how just i won't say
we'll reference it as you guys know and
uh yeah
when he has that moment with her it is
so it is so moving and it's such a
development of the kind of relationship
that they have that you do feel you know
when they when they say there's things i
buy into that i feel like in other shows
that'd be like i don't know man are we
really there yet to say that yeah like
when she's like i ca when when when
vessel mirrors i care about you and
she's like i care about all of you i
really believe her yeah or um it feels
earned you know when
when investment is like we shouldn't do
this to you you're a gerald's child i'm
like i believe that i i believe
that geralt does view her now as his
child and then vestemir would have it if
especially if you saw that shadow of the
nightmare of the like you know he has it
within him too to make those more
benevolent choices that are about
humanity more than about the bottom line
and getting more witchers out there you
know
investment really let himself go he did
a whole marlon brandon i know his whole
hair
beard style changed
now he looks like an aged biker
before he looked like carl urban
yeah
okay maybe at the end of the season
he'll bring his old look back before he
gets killed valiantly or some [ __ ] like
that
there's a lot of beautiful and i think
the way they they weave through normally
these episodes crescendo into some like
fight or something
and somehow this landed more of an
impact off of all the revelations that
it incurs
because there's a lot of revelations
that are happening here there's a lot
there's so much to unpack
wow that's
that's a thick episode of knowledge
right here
and they're good at making all that plus
all the different characters you're
hopping around to feel like yeah one big
living
world and that's part of why like you
know even though like rants uh if that's
the fire uh
fire bender but you know fire mage guy
like even though he trails off this
episode i still like you know even a
presence like that feels very formidable
and very tangible and so like they're
good at making that the case across the
board so kind of wherever we're putting
focus i'm always engrossed even if it's
like you know part way through you're
like oh yeah i kind of forgot about what
yen and you asked you were doing at the
same time not in like a bad way or like
and i'm bored with that kind of way or
this plot line is clearly way better
than those plot lines like it's it's got
uh that yeah that that ensemble vibe
even for characters that you don't know
as well and i think that's also just a
credit to how well they cast and how
well they realize this whole world
who's the witch at the beginning
um is that new she knew she just seems
like all eyes are on
seems like everyone's trying to get
okay that's why they wanted her
what's uh is he german
the guy who was hunter the fire mage guy
no not the fire mage guy the freaking uh
the dude at the end
who returns and sees
oh my gosh oh here's okay here yes yes
yeah yeah yeah with the beard yeah yeah
yeah
um
[Music]
okay so they wanted her because i mean
they keep saying the white flame but she
is like the secret weapon in a lot of
ways yeah the white flame must have some
acknowledgements all does come back to
her ultimately yeah yeah i mean because
yeah he was tasked with finding her for
the white flame and there's that whole
thing about her being like i don't think
he even wanted to hurt me the reason the
reason i brought the witch at the
beginning is because as if i as i've
been talking and trying to just like
talk about certain scenes i'm like wait
a minute there's so much information
here the the witch at the beginning
said she doesn't work for nilfgaard
so she's
another plot
another
yeah
in this ever throwing pot of people who
want to get to siri
so yeah okay yeah that's that's a lot
yeah yeah that's a lot
that is uh i don't wonder if it's it's a
little much to become a game of thrones
wait a minute i'm just remembering that
now yeah okay so you got random witch
lady who sent fire mage guy yes
her they got their one then you got the
the elves and uh
uh what's her what's her name girl
grinch russell
griselda there's gia there
uh which seems sincere uh some nilfgaard
and elves and and they're obviously
gonna want
siri yes of course
then uh
now you got the the witch
the the the mother deathless mother
who wants
i think that's what she's called
uh who wants
siri
well she she
is at least yeah pointing yen in siri's
direction whether that be for her own
end or to truly help yen get her powers
well i mean it's gonna be something it
sounds like it's something negative
seriously oh absolutely that will
ultimately lead to a terrible showdown
and confrontation with geralt and
jennifer
when having to deliver siri is the way
for jennifer to regain her powers
that's a lot going on damn that's that's
a lot of you guys what the [ __ ] there's
so much uh hey man maybe it's all right
there's so much information and then now
i'm freaking vessemeers in his own
little palace i just want to make more
witchers want more friends to hang out
with
there's only like 10 of us and you
killed one on the way in yeah that's
complicated ass stuff yes it's it's uh
it's growing far and wide yeah this
season was so far from brief like
i could keep up
with it we got we got a lot of moving
pieces here now
and then i'm like what
okay but somehow
i suppose the monoliths with the
monsters are meant to be
because it said that they were after
siri but there doesn't seem like they're
trying to kill siri mm-hmm
can you think of a moment where the
monsters were trying to kill siri
or are they like monster soldiers
meant to be like
yeah yeah they're drawn to her but yeah
is it is it a nefarious thing or is it a
homing thing yes that's a great question
where is that uh
big old
the churno bug that i knew off the top
where is that thing going is it going to
find her
because it just flies off immediately
it could be siri bound because yeah the
the leshi in the woods noticed her and
then the big old uh thing that he
brought to israel noticed her
maybe they're all like senpai notice me
unite the spheres send all the monsters
out to well it's because when they had
like what looked like the revelations in
the clouds i was like monsters are
riding on horses yeah
um so i don't know the horsemen of the
apocalypse probably won't get answered
they can't they gotta stretch this out
for as long as they can how many
episodes do we have left we got one two
three we only got three more yeah i
don't know how you could possibly
finish this in three but we'll see how
this goes they didn't definitely finish
the first one
um
yeah this one seems like it's gonna end
on an even bigger cliffhanger yeah
and maybe not feel those complete dip a
journey
could be yeah now that they're sure
they'll be around for a little while
all right guys well
thanks for sticking with us as we
figured out what we're talking about and
uh
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button let's do it
eric horstmann look john wanted to shout
you out i wanted to say something really
sincere because i know you had to go to
the hospital recently
and you haven't been doing all that well
so take it away john do the shout out
you were originally going to do okay hey
if there's anyone at patreon who i think
would be the perfect lecherous bard
in this universe it'd be you eric
horseman ah just imagine you with your
loot jumping around the bar wooing all
the young barkeep lads and whatnot oh
man you would have the best songs toss a
coin to your horsemen or or better yet i
guess we will we will toss some medical
insurance to our horse
uh just all fun and jokes here my man no
sincerity whatsoever just like we like
it but uh but seriously i hope you're
you're doing all right i can't i just
can't do it i can't i can't make light
of this
eric we love you and uh i hope you're
doing well and i hope that uh the new
year brings health and prosperity this
is a messy show this is a messy shout
out but i mean it from the heart
i meant the joke bit and the sincere bit
eric you're kind of going halfway on the
joke you might as well have fully
committed eric horstmann
oh valley of horstmann
is uh i'm going to right now i can't go
for comedy
all right if there's any place that you
should be hanging out it's caramel it's
like the locker room of the whole
witchery universe my friend that's where
you would swap war stories and you
probably as a witcher you probably would
walk around naked with your sword and
your potions and whatnot because that's
just your style and i want to see it on
this show there's not enough naked dudes
in the show
there's not been naked anybody in season
two
so let me get on it
there hasn't been anyone naked in this
show
i guess we could get naked
you suck the life
[Music]